yarr anybody in there okay
no all right then hello everybody my
name is markiplier and welcome back to
the joy of creation story mode now it's
time to go into the basement we don't
know what's waiting for us in the
basement but I have a funny feeling it's
Bonnie Freddy chica and foxy maybe a
little bit of Gould McCready because I
think I remember in the office sometimes
when you were going for Freddy do you
believe in spirits a little more many do
many claim they've seen one or have
heard stories of people being haunted by
these white figures or oily shadows my
dad made a game series about it of the
horror franchise in fact it was his
shining achievement apparently there was
a time when everybody knew about it all
over the world clothing toys accessories
board games you name it five nights at
Freddy's was everywhere there were even
rumors of it getting a movie well it
didn't last long anyway nobody remembers
it anymore
nor the characters the games or my
father
after that night it all went away
nothing lasts forever and that's why I
don't believe in spirits everyone has to
die everything has an end at some point
even at that point come sooner than
you'd wish okay all right what does it
have to do with going in the basement
that's awfully that's also a really sad
view of kids already there I found you
know daddy's here you must be really
scared but I'm here okay
I don't know what this looks bad I think
I remember bad memories
not the basement with foxy in it when
the demo I created you Freddy Bonnie
chica foxy hell how is this happening
what are you not you're just using their
faces how was that Michael talking is
that who that wheels ooh
press X Oh Waze des move left click to
interact with items f to turn the
flashlight on and off oh good good good
let's do this let's do this it's going
to the darkness and do this oh boy I bet
I'm gonna wake up in the inner
machinations of some saw type disaster
here where someone is going to test me
and if I don't succeed I will die a
horrible death okay alright alright okay
ah good yes you put me in the shitty
toilet oh girl thank you for that why is
this in my basement oh you are away yes
I oh hi hello this is so cool but also
so creepy you exist to let us out oh
okay alright then let us out open the
way or burn with the rest of them get
more monitors you could put of them
what were those those were some
conspicuous looking other monstrosity
Zin what is that
so my child's bedroom is that my bedroom
why do I have cameras in my house why oh
this is so creepy if this is it all real
I don't even know if it is
and I'm not gonna get any information
about this one I mind just gonna be left
to my own devices there seems to be a
lot of six on the walls here does that
have something to do with what I need to
do why who built this Oh Beth ice who
the hell hell built this who the Bingle
bonger Binker built this [ __ ] oh
[Music]
well that seems bad well then obviously
that doesn't work so there's something
else down here
okay why was that that was like a game
over screen from the last few nights
what was that all about
come back hello oh hi hello Oh goddamn
it
Oh
Shetty Dicky balls okay so I can't get
close to that thing
maybe I got to get through the door oh
boy no this is gonna kill me
I'm not sure what to do about that maybe
I'm gonna try to sneak over to the
bathroom again
why did I come in here I didn't need to
come in here oh ah we come from the fire
ah but our bodies meet shape huh Oh
bring his creations to us huh to ignite
our flame I need a cupcake any to
triangle I need a swirly do I need a a
roll no but I need to bring him is that
what I got it - is that what I gotta do
I gotta go back and forth in this
[ __ ] over and over again while
avoiding death sound what I gotta do hey
you were not safe I know I'm nothing go
back where I don't know what I'm gonna
do tag you're it oh god that was bad
idea why I shouldn't be up here oh oh no
I'm sick let's go back oh oh no oh god
no no
anyone in here in here I'm going back if
I can't run or anything so it kind of
just yeah oh no that's not what I was
hoping for dick oh I can't even go in
there
oh hi okay hello hi
I am in the furnace oh we come from the
fire okay so there must be like whoa
what the [ __ ] okay I got a hook I don't
know what this means but I got it okay
ah to ignite our flame so do I put this
in the furnace
is that what you want from me is that
what you want from me oh ah okay
that's in the furnace now well that's
good to know so there's got to be other
goober jabbers in here find the posters
maybe oh oh
didn't expect that did not expect that
did not expect that did not expect that
that's not what I expected I was totally
not about that you are in there my poor
heart can't take that Luke there we go
there we go how do I hear something over
here
I knew something was bad about that I
knew something was bad god damn it
oh god something oh hi okay how do I get
by you when you're right there
can I go in here will that make you go
away
nope you're still there okay that's a
problem hmm
about that Oh curious don't like it
can't get it in there really
Yeah right there okay got it back in a
way slowly okay alright okay okay yeah
yeah yeah
okay so just the cupcake is left I think
I don't know where that would be
it's gone quiet how does that make sense
how does that make sense
how does that make sense you just gotta
wait oh okay I didn't know I needed
patience for this I was just running
around frantically with my head chopped
off okay all right
made very little sense but let's try
this again got four more to go and that
one took a while hey shapes all similar
but different yeah all keeping us in
here with you the one he calls Michael
in the stories he formed find the key to
fit the lock avoid the ones lost to the
fire give him to us and we promise his
kindred to fill your desires okay all
right
who the hell are you talking about why
is someone in there that looks like the
shape of somebody and I don't like that
oh okay find the key to fit the lock oh
is it a code oh it's a code thing isn't
it all right okay I see oh I see you
there huh don't think I don't see you
okay six nine two three six nine two
three is that what it is
nope okay couldn't have been that simple
ah wait okay the numbers coincide with
the number of creatures 9 6 3 2 is it
yeah there we go I'm not sure I'm too
happy about this but there we go
okay hi the [ __ ] oh boy
oh hi okay doop boop boop
oh that's not good all righty then
hi hello how are you doing I'm fine
thank you very much please go away [ __ ]
how do I close this goddamn door can I
close this goddamn door
probably not I can't can I okay he's
right there caught on the door I don't
know where I'm going
oh boy that one's in the middle right
there how do I get through this [ __ ]
with him right there oh [ __ ] oh that's
no good oh god it's uh it's Co of course
it's over there I don't know the code
for this one oh oh oh oh okay
ah wait what's that on the other wall
okay it's a bear with three horror
health bags presents that means nothing
but that one Oh bear - - bear is that
that might be foxy I have no idea that's
obviously Freddy was three presents oh
there we go Bonnie with four so Freddy
at three Bonnie four foxy two as it
leaves chica with one right oh I see
okay they're colored okay she could
first foxy second Oh Freddy third Bonnie
sick what okay okay okay okay
open open open open open open is there
something on the other side of that
fence let me just get in position where
I could see that and him does it look
like it I think I got it yeah all right
let's go for this hello anybody up the
stairs I should worry about no oh but
there's a blockade why is there a
blockade
oh god oh wait oh no oh what did I just
do
oh oh I can't close it behind me oh I
didn't know I could do that okay that
still doesn't help me oh oh the key what
oh I got the key and he's gone
alrighty then that was weird
where is he is he here he's still here
okay weird
got the key I don't know I you know I
don't know I don't know what you want
from me oh hey subsea okay where am I
now oh boy oh boy this is PI P I love
pipe good thing you got strip loss o
pipe because that's my favorite thing to
have when I'm in the dark basement and
fearing for my life there's something
behind me should I look behind me
interesting alrighty then pressing
forward because I got nothing better to
do and I have a funny feeling I'm gonna
die okay that's okay don't look back I'm
not gonna look back
why would I look back why would I look
back I'm not the type of person to look
back no matter what maybe find me I'm
not the type of person to look back and
I'm not gonna look back no matter what
you tell me no matter how long how
strong I want to look back I'm not gonna
look back no way nohow there's no way in
hell that I would ever look back because
if I were to look back and when there's
a door right in front of me okay I look
back but I did it
back that's why you don't stupidly look
back cuz that'd be dumb that'd be rude
or dumb
alright number two oh that was number
three own we act we posed we played we
stopped we stared we scream we bring his
visions to life because that is how much
we live feeding from the joy of creation
and bringing what remains I go free oh
he remains Oh yummy yummy
oh boy that is there's not good oh god
oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god go
through the middle here oh whoa
there's someone behind me is it just the
two of them
Oh Oh hi
Oh God alright okay alright we're fine
we're fine there's a button over there
I'm gonna press that that's nice nice
button oh hi what the [ __ ] you telling
me these goddamn [ __ ] over here
oh hi oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh my god okay all right okay all
right okay I got this I got this
I know what to do I know what to do Oh
like a butterfly like a butterfly holy
[ __ ] I saw that movement that's Bidoof
meant ain't a Hooven nobody you guys
stay over there I'm gonna go up this
stairs now baby I'm going up the stairs
now holy [ __ ] badass oh did I get
the key do it oh no door oh we're in no
door land oh no door no door hold the
door no door we ain't going nowhere
Hodor the furnace is gone that button do
nothing I got a bad feeling about this
just like everything in this basement
surprisingly I know I have a bad feeling
about this
Oh everything's gone excuse me pardon me
sorry I know that was rude
fear burps and all that one more puzzle
to get through you think about the logic
of this like none of this makes any
sense it's all in his mind poor Scott on
Scott's my oh that is dark okay all
right then
this silly hello oh it's his computer
look he's making some Fred boy oh there
isn't even a door there anymore there
was nothing in the first place it's all
rude
fools why is this open I don't like the
fact I made it simple tricks of the mind
or something more sinister
I don't know accounts of these strange
apparitions present and all the way back
since ancient Egyptian mythology telling
chilling tales of ghostly doubles with
sightings usually precede horrible
tragedy for the people whose faces
they've stolen we interview many who
claim to have seen or experienced these
encounters of their own evil twin oh I
don't know what that means but either
way that is the end of the basement all
that is left is the Attic I called it I
knew it and somehow I don't feel any
better for it because I see a little
going Freddy plushie right there in the
doorway this game is amazing I love this
game Oh like I said I would have paid
money for this this is so well made
because it's so well made oh my god
but either way thank you everybody so
much for watching hope you enjoyed this
one let me know what you think down the
comments below and as always I will see
you in the next video
[Music]